seems to me that the characteristics of
a good egg system service
decision-making system actually boil
down to just three you need sound
silence you need sound valuation and you
also need sound costing and costing may
not be the same as valuation and I'll
come on to that right at the end of the
talk so when it go through all three of
these but I want to start with some
context and the UK context is
particularly interesting because we they
actually take it seriously there they
really do make decisions on the basis of
the ecosystem service approach and on
valuations of ecosystem services they've
got one of the longest histories of
applying it and you can see the variety
of applications there so taxis for
landfill for cars regulation of wetlands
first and then nearly all natural areas
now recreation both urban and rural
being planned using values climate
policy being driven by values I think it
was a valid attempt what they tried to
do is say well you know you can
decompose the UK into a whole set of
habitats and you can look at the various
values that these generate and therefore
each sale tells you about how important
a given habitat is to a given service so
obviously in close farmland is very
important for crops that's way it's
shaded dark the arrows are the things
that are interesting though they tell
you about the trend in that service is
it going up is it going down do we not
know it whatever and so obviously with
that particular example it's going
firmly up because food productivity has
expanded over time quite dramatically
this was looking at the period from the
end of the Second World War onwards we
can simplify that just in a few bullet
points and basically say that since the
end of the war there's been a big
increase in provisioning but has been
decreases in lots of other
system services over the last 10 to 20
years that have been discernable changes
in the path of each system service
delivery some services still declining
rapidly some of them beginning to show a
reduction in the rate of decline partly
as a result of various regulations
others actually beginning to improve but
overall by 2010 we've got a status
situation where about thirty five
percent are still declining some from
very low levels and about twenty percent
are improving the remainder constant or
unclear we tried to come up with
marginal values and also to use them at
most leads we were very interested in
trying to get Mel at marginal value
functions if possible rather than
constants because you would expect
marginal values to change as the
provision of a good changes and then we
try to work out when I say totals I'm
talk about total totals of changes from
a baseline under a different a set of
different scenarios I'm going to
illustrate some of the procedures that
we did by looking at those scenarios
here they are six scenarios there was
actually each one of them is doubled
because each one operates for a low
emission and a high emission variant you
can see from the names the sort of
things that these scenarios look at now
these scenarios were come word arrived
for a process that is not the way I'd
have done it but following it was a
political science approach talking to
decision-makers about the sort of future
worlds that they were interested in or
that they were worried in and coming up
with a set of functions which would end
up with which would be consequent from
those different policies
we're going to look in particular at two
of them one's called nature at work
where there's a priority to enhance
ecosystem services and the other one
world markets where there's unfettered
economic growth and trade liberalization
because we know we can predict for other
periods what we can nail do is
reassemble all the data we estimate it
and they'll say or what happens when
something changes and the thing that
anybody's really interested in of course
is climbing so what happens when climate
changes and climate is going to change
quite significantly across the UK you
can see up there rainfall it's actually
going to get drier during the growing
season temperature thank God it's
actually going to get warmer so what
will this do to farming well it'll
change the pattern of farming quite
dramatically out to the future this is
colored with green being increases and
red being decreases and if we see here
across this bottom layer a crop called
oilseed rape I don't know if you have it
over here but it likes drier conditions
and you can see all that green coming up
as the future gets drier and warmer
quite a number of areas currently used
for dairying will actually become less
suitable because of exactly the same
factors area it's getting drier warmer
less suitable for pasture what's this
mean in terms of these scenarios the
scenarios very not only climate they
also chair very what's happening in
policy we can now put all of these
values together these are the initials
of the six scenarios doesn't matter what
they are we're only just focusing on
these end to ones here so we've got
nature at work and world market remember
the agricultural story if we just look
at market values
then nature at work stinks it actually
is worse than the present day that's why
I've colored it red whereas will markets
is fantastic nice green color cuz it
looks a lot better than the present day
actually the second highest net present
value that you get out of any of these
scenarios it looks really good but
that's just considering one aspect of
each system services provisioning and we
now know there's loads of them there's
carbon and Recreation all those other
ones over there and what's more they all
change spatially and they change again
under different scenarios so you have
massive change available to you now
let's go back to that situation and add
in all those are the values and you can
see the result completely flips on its
head actually world markets is bad for
the UK for UK plc it actually generates
a net value which is worse than the
present day whereas nature at work comes
out with the highest value if you're
interested all these results have on the
web and instead of just this simple
ranking you've actually got the monetary
numbers attached to each one of them